estamos en el hospital infantil de
odessa donde se ha habilitado este
subterráneo para cuidar a los niños que
atienden ellos la mayoría de ellos son
neonatos a los que trabajan aquí o niños
que han sufrido alguna cirugía ha sido
interesante ver especialmente la cara de
las madres o de sus padres que
constantemente no solamente pasan los
días y las noches con nuestros niños en
el hospital toda la preocupación de que
estos niños estén aquí durante una
guerra sino toda la situación que tiene
que venir pasar aquí horas esperar a que
la alarma se acabe lo que crea muchísima
más ansiedad hablábamos con varias de
estas familias algunas de ellas no se
quieren ir de odessa porque no tienen
las circunstancias o no quieren
abandonar al padre o son familias
numerosas sin embargo obviamente toda
esta preocupación como hablábamos se
hace aún mayor cuando estos niños están
enfermos y hay que pasar horas y horas
en un hospital aunque también hay que
decir que este subterráneo está mejor
equipado y está más protegido que otros
lugares de la ciudad porque a diferencia
de ciudades como en otras grandes
ciudades de ucrania aquí en odessa no
hay tan buenos subterráneos dicen que no
están tan bien equipados así que muchas
de las población se queda en sus casas
cuando suenan las alarmas